what's up shots of off fans Jason Silva
here letting you know that July is
creativity month here on shots of awe
which means that every video we post
will be about creativity
it'll be about exploring that liminal
trance state that magical borderland
between dreams and reality that space in
which we connect the dots will fall down
the rabbit hole will fall through the
looking-glass it will be amazing so make
sure you subscribe here on youtube or
like my page on facebook and of course
click on the link in the description to
see the playlist on creativity this is
Jason Silva thanks for watching shots of
I love you guys
you